the sun is about 93 million miles away
which means it takes about eight minutes
for light from the sun to reach
earth but it's still close enough for us
to take advantage of solar energy
and why wouldn't we want to after all
solar energy is renewable and
essentially inexhaustible it's also a
clean
energy source so more and more we're
turning to solar energy to
directly warm our homes or indirectly
generate
electricity the first type of solar
heating we'll talk about
is called passive as the name suggests
passive
happens without much work on your end in
my mind it's the equivalent of you just
lying out in the sun
which is why throughout the world this
method is the most
widely accessible and inexpensive some
examples of how homes can be
passively heated are through the actual
materials that the home is made out of
so materials like stone concrete
adobe they absorb a lot of the sun's
heat
during the day and then slowly release
it
at night if we use this adobe house as
an example
the thick walls and small sunken in
windows
keep the house sheltered from the sun
during the day
and then at night the clay material that
it's made out of
releases that heat energy that it's
stored throughout the day
so this particular home is located in
santa fe new mexico
and a lot of homes that are in desert
areas like this
are made out of clay and for good reason
because during the day
in desert locations it can get very hot
and that clay will absorb the heat
keeping the inside of the house pretty
cool and then at night
desert areas can get very very cold and
so that clay will release the heat
and keep the house moderately
comfortable
or in the northern hemisphere some homes
are built with
south-facing windows which increases the
number of hours that
sunlight comes into the home so these
are ways to
passively warm a home but there may be
situations in which you want to just
block the sun's heat and light to cool
down the home instead
for example the color of the roof can
make a big difference in how much heat
does or doesn't get stored in the home
painting the roof a light color will
reflect the sun's heat energy much like
choosing to wear a white t-shirt instead
of a black shirt
on a hot summer day there's also a
specialty type of roof
called a green roof where plants are
grown on
top of the home to provide an additional
layer of insulation
now i haven't personally been on one but
i can only imagine in the springtime
if there are flowers planted in the
green roofs they must smell
and look amazing and of course you can
also
create shade by planting trees around
the home
or adding awnings above the windows
to use solar energy in a different way
we can move from passive techniques to
active ones for example some homes have
big panels attached to the roofs called
solar collectors
these solar collectors work by heating
up a fluid
inside of them and then use pumps or
fans
to circulate that fluid and transfer
heat
into the home to warm up the air or
water in the home
so the use of these pumps or fans to
move the heat into the home
is what makes this active heating rather
than just
passive a different alternative if you
happen to have a very large area of
space
is a concentrated solar power
system or csp for short
which is basically a lot of reflectors
that concentrate that solar energy
one specific type uses mirrors to
reflect that solar energy onto a single
tower that energy can then be used to
boil water
create steam and ultimately generate
electricity
the largest csp in the united states is
in the mojave desert
very near california's border with
nevada
it's called the ivampa solar power
facility
you'll see here that there are three
sets of concentric circles
with mirrors that are reflecting heat
energy onto
individual towers and there are hundreds
of thousands of mirrors the plant takes
up
three thousand five hundred acres of
land
and can power more than a hundred
thousand homes
in california the downsides of these
systems though is that they do cost a
lot of money in space up front
and if the weather is bad they don't
work as well
there are also stories a few years back
where there are
hundreds of birds quite literally being
burned up as they flew between the
mirrors and the towers
so you can imagine the enormous amount
of heat energy that's being reflected
off these mirrors on the upside these
reflectors can be cheaper to maintain
than
other technologies and can make use of
large stretches of desert that
are already empty all over the world
and finally one other way to harness the
power of the sun
is through photovoltaic cells if we
break down that big word
photo meaning light and volt
meaning a unit of electric force
then photovoltaic becomes using light to
produce
electric force this idea dates back to
1905 when einstein first published a
paper about it
he then went on to win the nobel prize
for this concept
of the photoelectric effect that when
light shines on a metal it causes
electrons to be ejected
and generates an electric current
photovoltaic cells are used in solar
farms
on the roofs of houses and you might
even have your very own solar powered
calculator
you'll notice these types of calculators
work best outside or
in a bright room which can definitely be
a disadvantage in some cases
another disadvantage is that sometimes
you'll have to install
large amounts of these to generate
enough electricity for say
a home which can get expensive and you
also have to be sure you're not moving
anytime soon
on the other hand installing solar
panels on a home reduces
electricity costs and your carbon
footprint
so there you go lots of ways to harness
the power of the sun
both its heat and its light